cette mesure réclamée depuis des jours
ne visera finalement que certaines
questions fins financières russes alors
qu'est ce que les pays occidentaux
cherchent à faire précisément ils
cherchent à empêcher
qu'il y est effectivement une solution
duc les airs dans lequel la russie ne
fournirait plus d'énergie et l'europe ne
serait plus en mesure de la payer donc
elle a limité son intervention suivra
des grandes banques et le paiement qui
se fait avec les entreprises comme
gazprom et du col va pouvoir continuer à
se faire ce qui permettra de maintenir
l'approvisionnement énergétique de
l'europe il fallait trouver une sorte de
compromis et donc on devait pouvoir
arriver à le faire de manière à la fois
efficace et en même temps bien cadré bon
on a beaucoup parlé de swift depuis
quinze jours mais peut-être plus
importante ce sont les mesures annoncées
et qui visent la banque centrale russe
oui c'est extrêmement important parce
que le l'on dit toujours que les
réserves russes sont importantes c'est
environ 680 milliards de dollars elles
sont détenues par la banque centrale et
elles sont détenues par la banque
centrale à travers des comptes en
dollars à la federal reserve en euros à
la banque centrale européenne et en
dollars canadiens la banque du canada
cet argent là maintenant on va être
partiellement gelée et c'est exactement
ce que madame von der leyen a dit dans
votre reportage on cherche non pas à
isoler la russie on cherche à étrangler
l'effort de guerre russe et c'est donc
pour cela que maintenant on va limiter
la possibilité de la russie de faire
appel à ses propres réserves pour
financer la guerre et on veut réduire
l'accès aussi de la banque centrale
russe aux marchés des capitaux pour
empêcher quoi moi ce coup de soutenir le
cours du rouble qui est en recul en
raison de la guerre absolument parce que
si on veut sauter le cours du rouble on
doit utiliser les devises mais ça ne
sera pas possible étant donné les
limitations de la banque centrale ceci
dit le rouble est au plus bas depuis
toute son histoire par rapport au dollar
les mesures précédentes déjà en tue un
effet extrêmement important à la fois
sur le rouble sur la bourse et sur le
commerce est donc comment mesures vont
empêcher la russie de financer son
effort de guerre maintenant
écouter pour pouvoir financer sur les
soifs fort de guerre au début elle va
pouvoir utiliser ses ressources à mort
donnée elle va devoir avoir besoin
d'équipement elle va avoir besoin aussi
de payer un certain nombre de ses
fournisseurs shakey elle a acheté
notamment des obus etc et je vous
signale quand même mais par exemple dans
l'aviation qui est un autre problème en
plus ils 80% de l'aviation à des pièces
de rechange qui viennent en dehors de
russie donc la russie est extrêmement
dépendante pour flat d'avoir un système
de paiement qu'ils soient tout à fait
libre et le fait que le monde entier je
dirais prend comme décision de
l'étrangler sauf pour le passage
énergétique est à mon avis la bonne
solution mais ça va faire mal à la pompe
parce que inévitablement l'énergie va
coûter plus cher et ce sera efficace
selon vous pour a tenté d'arrêter cette
guerre
je crois que nous ne pouvons pas espérer
voir 1-1 pas arrêter la guerre
simplement par ces mesures là sur le
long terme et même sur le court terme ça
ça devient très difficile pour le
président poutine par contre il faut
bien se rendre compte que l'alternative
par rapport à ce type de mesures ce
serait d'entrer en guerre avec la russie
et ça je crois personne ne le veut merci
beaucoup monsieur jeu d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir
bonne soirée